A new villain enters the picture in "Mission:
Impossible — Dead Reckoning Part One."
While he has his merits, we can't help but
long for the return of the bad guy who made
such a huge impact in the previous film.
Warning: Spoilers for "Dead Reckoning Part
One" ahead!
In a franchise fueled on secrets and high-tech
surprises that make the mission all that much
more difficult, "Dead Reckoning Part One"
distinctly lacked when it came to the shock
factor.
Sure, there were a few twists here and there,
and jaws dropped seeing Tom Cruise riding
a dirtbike and ditching it mid-flight, but
it lacked something that the previous movie,
"Fallout," had: a perfect opposing force against
Ethan Hunt.
Henry Cavill's August Walker elevates "Fallout"
to some of the highest highs of the "Mission:
Impossible" franchise.
He's the hammer to Hunt's scalpel, and their
final showdown on the side of a Himalayan
mountain is an epic one that demonstrates
Cavill could be just as magnetic trying to
end the world as he was trying to save it
in other roles.
"This proves nothing.
I'm playing a role.
Just like you are."
Esai Morales' Gabriel slides into the lead
villain role in "Dead Reckoning: Part One,"
and he provides a different kind of threat.
He's a smoother operator, and frankly, pales
in comparison to Cavill's hulking but equally
manipulative mastermind.
The revelation that Cavill's fist-reloading
CIA man was the brains behind Ethan's problems
made August Walker more of a force to be reckoned
with than Gabriel could ever be.
Morales' Gabriel gains an edge thanks to a
powerful AI called The Entity, but it actually
makes him a less compelling foe.
As the messenger for the Entity, Morales'
antagonist almost feels like the "Mission:
Impossible" answer to The Architect from "The
Matrix."
He's a jargon-spouting man of mystery that
doesn't really feel like much of an imposing
figure.
Also, while Gabriel is supposed to have a
history with Hunt, it doesn't really feel
like it.
Everything has to be filled in with flashbacks,
referring to characters who have never been
mentioned before.
That's where Walker making a comeback would
feel so much more impactful.
We've seen these two go toe-to-toe.
We know they can push each other's buttons,
and seeing more of that would make any future
"Mission: Impossible" chapter with Cavill
all the more enjoyable.
It'd be the perfect time to have him pay a
return visit as well, given his current schedule.
"You're not getting rid of me that easily,
Hunt."
After hanging up the cape as Superman and
passing the White Wolf onto Liam Hemsworth
for "The Witcher," seeing him strut back on
the scene for "Mission: Impossible", twice
as angry and just as unhinged, would be welcome.
More importantly, it could cement Cavill as
one of the most consequential villains in
the "Mission: Impossible" franchise.
He'd be a Blofeld to Ethan Hunt's Bond, if
you will.
As the world waits with bated breath for a
new James Bond to hit the big screen, Ethan
Hunt and his ensemble of spies have the espionage
action market covered at the moment.
Calling upon Henry Cavill could establish
August Walker as a permanent threat to Hunt,
just as Blofeld has long been for Bond.
Much like the lunatic with the top SPECTRE
spot, Walker has already shown his managerial
skills by handling The Apostles while hiding
in plain sight.
If he managed to go that long without being
detected, it wouldn't be that much of a shock
to see him make a killer comeback as an even
more maniacal force.
There is, of course, the matter of Walker
having died by falling off that mountain in
"Fallout," but bringing him back from the
dead wouldn't be such a wild idea.
Longtime Tom Cruise collaborator Christopher
McQuarrie, who directed the last three entries
in the "Mission: Impossible" franchise, told
The Hollywood Reporter in 2021,
"I'm in the process of rewriting 'Mission
8' right now, this afternoon I could turn
a page and any actor from the past could come
back.
There is no such thing as death in movies,
only unavailability."
What better way to throw Hunt off balance
than setting up a rematch we'd all be hyped
to see?
The stunts in "Dead Reckoning: Part One" are
great, but they'd have been even better under
the looming shadow of a former foe with thunderous
fists.